foreign
next up we have Jose and Montecito
California hey Jose welcome to the show
hi guys how are you we're doing great
how can we help
so um
I kind of got myself into a little bit
of a predicament here I
I will I have I have a truck so it's an
older vehicle that I've been using uh to
commute back and forth from work well
however I was getting tired of paying so
much in gas and because you know in
California that gas is pretty expensive
over here
um
so I went and purchased a smaller
vehicle more economic uh
which was great
but I didn't really pay attention too
much to the uh interest rate afterwards
the vehicle the vehicle costs it out the
door was 19 000.
um
but afterwards when I looked at the
paperwork I have a 28 interest
whoa Amigo what are you doing oh no Jose
oh my gosh I secured the cleaners how
much did you owe on that truck
uh no the truck was paid off that was
that was my truck I got that truck for
like four thousand dollars so you gave
somebody nineteen thousand dollars at 28
to save
50 bucks a month on gas
what I thought was gonna be a little bit
better but shoot okay what could you say
Okay Jose what could you sell the car
for today have you Kelly Blue booked it
yeah and I even went back to the same
place that I got it from only for them
to tell me that their trade-in value
will only be 17 000.
do you still have it
I still have the truck is worth a like
about six thousand okay so Jose what
you're gonna do is I would get out of
this loan ASAP okay so what you're gonna
have to do is take a smaller loan a two
thousand dollar loan for the difference
to get out of the car because you're
upside down on it and I would rather you
owe two thousand dollars with a loan
from the bank not at 28 go to a credit
union then have a car that's continuing
to depreciate the more you drive it
and it's this yeah I mean it's
astronomical interest rates so stupid so
I would get out of that today Jose I
really would and you'll get a loan for
two thousand dollars and I would drive
your paid off truck and not have
payments and start tackling this this
two grand I'd rather you owe two grand
than 28 grand and we say this for 19
Grand we see this with love but we're
kind of clowning a little bit but
basically you're going to end up with
about a two thousand dollar stupid tax
okay yeah yeah unfortunately and then
you're gonna be like next time
somebody's like hey I got this good idea
you're gonna go no way man I remember
that by the way if the trade-in value
was 17 000 at this scam artist that sold
you this car that's a great point I bet
you could sell it for twenty thousand
dollars private sale and net a grand on
it yes that's a great Point Jose
yeah don't go back to them see if you
can private sell I would put this on
Facebook Marketplace tonight and see
what you can put it for 21 000 and see
what you get for it yep
is it a brand new car is it brand new
it's it's a 2022 uh Chevy Spark okay yep
I would actually I put it at 22 and
someone's gonna give you 20 think in
there get they're getting a deal
and they'll just say how about just 20.
and
then you go uh okay and then you're
gonna make a thousand bucks and you're
gonna have a thousand dollars for all
your indigestion and probably a little
bit of Preparation H and then you're all
done and you're never gonna do this
again that's right yeah no no lesson
lesson learned okay but yeah until
you start going no I was gonna say that
last piece of advice that John said is
so true that I'm like this could make or
break that two grand loan or not
actually coming out ahead so remember
there's all you're always going to get a
better deal most of the time through a
private sale when you go to a dealership
not as good and especially if you're
going back to the people that sold it to
you and you're like please take it back
you're like we will for 17 because they
know in their house hey uh have you been
through financial peace brother
I actually just signed up to it um I
start on the sixth awesome good most
excellent all right here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna send you a free copy
of Total Money Makeover and I want you
to have that as just as your gift from
us and I want you to read that book as
you're entering into this class it's
going to be a great primer as you launch
into this class good for you man
awesome thank you so much thank you for
your time man I like you Jose here
thanks I mean you would be friends I'm
confident of it and you know what John I
think so much of all of this idea of
winning with money looking at your life
making different decisions there's a
level of humility that you have to be
like oh that was a stupid decision I
feel like we've had some callers call in
and we'll get off the call and we're
like we'll say to each other
take our advice because you can just
feel it from them that's like no I got
my thing I'm gonna do my thing and they
keep running down that same track that
we're like warning warning warning don't
do it don't do it so there takes a level
of continuing to learn
and to believe that like okay not
everything I thought was correct is
correct like I need to learn something
new and maybe the decisions I've made
with my money are stupid and not good so
I need to make different decisions right
like there's a basic human element there
that's really key to change your
behavior so there's two things and I
I'll keep in private here between me and
my counselor but there's two things that
have a struggle with for decades yeah
for years yeah and yesterday in my
counseling session my couch is the
greatest my therapist the greatest she's
incredible but she said
how long
and I said what do you mean she said how
long are you gonna keep working this
plan that has never worked at what point
and she used the word that I hate with
all my guts at what point are you gonna
submit to another way of of looking at
this problem yeah and that was the most
honest true thing I could have been told
the way I'm doing this isn't working so
we talked to a caller earlier that
um him and his buddy they created a
company and they built a house and now
they're having to float the note of
their private bank accounts interest
only because they have a scheme I think
and those dudes can't breathe and it's
it's a like okay you tried it you got
crypto you got it's not working
will you be interested in trying
something else just a totally different
way of doing life and that's Jose's
that's why I pointed all that out
because like he came with such like
humility this humility
so you guys sometimes it's just that
admitting I messed up it's my fault as
Taylor Swift would say hi it's me I'm
the problem it's me